it's a very lovely
and charming gown for a lovely and
charming princess that we're about to
meet
uh anna mae wilson looks at us over wnhc
tv in new haven asked for it
see right i constantly marvel at the way
motion pictures can completely transform
an actress's appearance on the screen
through a selection of wardrobe is it
possible to have a studio designer
explain that
well anime yes one of those amazing
transformations for which hollywood is
famous was recently completed for this
delightful little actress audrey hepburn
who achieved stardom overnight due to
her starring role in paramount's roman
holiday now it all started right here in
the office of edith's head she is a
costume designer for paramount and this
head is out of my class here to ask
about ladies wardrobes or know anything
about it but you being a four-time
academy award winner can kind of set us
straight huh well try mr baker well the
question is here how do you go about
changing actress's appearances just
through water
the first thing i do is to get
acquainted with the actress actually
study her
now in the case of audrey hepburn she
was in europe at that time on stage
so it was necessary for us to film what
we call a personality test in other
words we wanted to see how she could
move how she could walk and generally
how she looked on the screen would you
like to see the results yes indeed we
would
now this is an actual test this was made
in england flown to me here in hollywood
it was my first acquaintance with audrey
hepburn and as you'll see it's pretty
successful
all right now wander down here without
your hands in your pockets and settle
down in that chair and make a nice
close-up of y'all
said it's the okay tell us about the
wall you spent the whole war in honor
yes
wasn't for your phone
this is very bad
but did you entertain the people there
yourself is that how you began
no not quite how i began i went to
ballet school once i knew i was settled
there for quite a while
didn't know how long the war was going
to last so i went to a ballet school and
learned to dance
and in about
1944
about a year before the end of the war i
was quite capable of performing
and it was a sort of
some way in which i could
make some contribution and
i did give performances to
collect money for the underground which
always needed money and what about the
germans what did they do about it
there's nobody
what a delightful girl she is and that
personality has so much better than
still pictures they like meeting her
face
of course they are and you know it was
from that test that i was able to design
these costumes
then after making these costumes i flew
to new york i actually met the pepper
and made this water test
this is the first time that you see ms
hepburn on the screen in a test testing
in the costume for roman holiday you see
she is supposed to be a princess
disguised as an ordinary girl on the
streets of rome so we made her a simple
costume so she wouldn't look different
and you know why she's rolling up her
sleeves and all of these things it's
because in the picture she had to look
casual informal and we felt due to the
heat of roman summer a girl would really
do this sort of thing
now watch and see what she does now
because this is what we call
demonstrating through a test what is
going to happen in a picture it helps
the director and it helps an actress you
see she's whirling around because in the
picture she has to ride a motorcycle
see it proves it
oh her pretty hair was cut off in the
picture that's part of the story too now
this is a transformation as the princess
you see we don't do any tricks or give
her a crown but we give her a regal
dress a simple dress of real lace in
other words the type dress that a real
princess would wear
under similar circumstances in a similar
locale
this is what we call transformation
through wardrobe
real regal that's realistic it really is
late and the princess could have worn
this dress
and audrey wears this dress in the
picture
it accomplishes that regal feeling there
yeah here is an even more regal costume
this is one of the princesses ball gowns
for the opening of the film
we had two costumes from which to choose
and we took this one of silver brocade
because it was a little more
photographic a little gayer now you
notice what she's going to do now she is
turning around the picture because the
producer william weiler said it's too
long she can't possibly death now audrey
who is an accomplished dancer says just
watch me and that is why she did it in
the test
and she wears it in the picture
does that answer your request oh so much
more delightful than we expected indeed
well roman holiday uh your work in that
you must be congratulated i kind of see
another academy award coming well i'm
more certain that the picture itself
will win an academy was because mr
wilder's direction was marvelous he
always has good ones there everyone's
talking about this audrey hepburn i can
see why too and of course he had gregory
peck and eddie albert they're
outstanding i must say that having seen
the picture this one of the recent ones
that i look at people and say roman
holiday you've got to see thank you very
much indeed for answering this request
what a great pleasure mr baker and for
you anime wilson in new haven there we
saw a bit of hollywood magic before our
eyes because you asked for it